so as we continue with age of Ultron
issue number four we again pick up with
Luke Cage as he realizes that the vision
is actually occupying this current point
within the Ultron city that it's not
actually Ultron who's here now at the
moment we don't know if Ultron is the
one that's controlling everything
through vision or if it's actually the
vision who has somehow gone awry and is
controlling everything but what the
vision asks Luke Cage is what it is that
he has to offer and Luke Cage asked
older asked the vision if he's the one
that did all this if he's the one that
he's talking to and vision says that
Ultron can hear him that Ultron can see
Luke Cage and for the most part Luke
Cage doesn't really know what to make of
this Luke Cage is a little unsure and he
again asks where it is that Ultron is at
presuming that Ultron may very well be
in a different city or perhaps out in
space or something like that but what
the vision tells us is that Ultron isn't
even in this current time that Ultron is
actually in the future that he's
controlling everything from the future
he's controlling these Ultron robots and
he is to a degree controlling the vision
now the vision says this of his own
accord indicating to us that Ultron is
really more I guess using the vision
more of like a window to control the
past more so than outright controlling
the vision and so the vision seems to be
used simply as a conduit for all trying
to control the past and what the what
the vision says once I guess Ultron
regains control at him is too is asking
again Luke Cage what it is that he has
to offer but she Hulk has overheard
enough at this point she realizes that
there's really only one Road from this
point and so what she does is tell Luke
Cage to get out of here and to tell Tony
Stark everything he's overheard from
here Luke Cage is a little surprised by
this and Luke Cage is actually reluctant
to leave and so she Hulk throws him out
of the building from this point she Hulk
again goes on a tangent and says that
she's that she believes that she's
almost the strongest one there is and
she begins to to defeat or I guess to
tear apart these various forms of the
Ultron robots but just as she's
beginning to gain the upper hand one of
the Ultron robots is able to shoot her
in the side of the head with a laser
beam and effectively kill her from this
point we see the vision is a little
disheartened to realize that she's dead
and that he really is helpless to stop
any of this from happening and so as
luke cage's being I guess is landing
after his throw from the building the
ultra on robots begin to pursue him and
again because Luke Cage has
indestructible skin there really isn't a
whole lot they can do to defeat him and
so Luke Cage begins to take out his rage
and aggression on them he tells them
that they killed his wife that they
killed his baby that they killed his
friends but as Luke Cage is again
preparing to try to defeat these Ultron
robots that it appears at what's taking
place is a nuclear blast over New York
City now we don't know exactly whether
or not Luke Cage survives this nuclear
blast yet all we know is that at this
point there's been a massive explosion
within the the immediate vicinity of
downtown Manhattan from here we pick up
with marc spector
and natasha romanoff and what natasha
romanoff is telling us here is that she
was able to open the black box that they
were previously unable to open and that
within this black box are Fury's nick
fury's into the world scenarios one of
which is a situation in which ultron was
able to take over the world and the
question the marc spector is asking here
is what are they supposed to do what's
supposed to happen next
natasha romanoff says that Nick Fury had
a series of secret bunkers all over the
world and that one of the bunkers was
designed to be an end-of-the-world
bunker and that this end of the world
bunker is located in the Savage Land
indicating to us that both the forces of
Captain America as well as Natasha
Romanov and marc spector will most
likely all end up meeting together
within the savage land proper at this
point we transition to eight days later
and what we see is that the forces of a
Captain America's team have arrived in
the Savage Land but rather than finding
a Savage Land which may very well have
been free from the destruction of
Ultron's forces they instead founds
have--is land has been riddled with
destruction there are various potholes
and they appear to be nuclear explosions
around various portions of the of the
area and again they found a jet here a
Avengers jet the question they have is
who it was that fluid here and how it
landed or who it was it did this again
The Invisible Woman is keeping them
invisible for the most part so they're
trying to do what they can to decipher
what it is is taking place before going
further because for all they know it
could very well be another Ultron
robot or some other third party they're
unaware of who is somehow managed to
land and the Savage Land but as they're
investigating the area they realize that
there is a man on the hilltop and when
they reach this hilltop they realize
that it's kazar the lord of the Savage
Land
now kazar is a character that we haven't
necessarily gotten into yet for a good
reason that reason being because for the
most part he's not a wildly important
character and the realm of Marvel Comics
at the moment he's more important back
in the 90s but for this point he's
really not a major player in this story
but what he tells us is that when
Ultron's forces began to overrun the
world when they began to take over that
they invaded everywhere which included
the Savage Land and that what's left
these various huts in this small little
village is all this left of of Khazars
people of the various people spread
across the Savage Land who have managed
to come together to try to keep
themselves safe but he also tells them
that within one of these Hut's
is what it is they're looking for Emma
Frost uses her telepathic abilities and
realizes that within this Hut is Luke
Cage and that Luke Cage had piloted the
Avengers jet that they had found and
apparently had been irradiated due to
the fallout from the nuclear explosion
that he's alive but that none of them
need to go in there and see him most
likely indicating that he's a
grotesquely disfigured as a result of
his exposure to the nuclear blast and
she tells us that Luke Cage after the
explosion had crawled to to safety had
managed to make it into the jet and then
crawled to this village within the
Savage Land and what Luke Cage tells
Emma Frost telepathically is that Ultron
is not in this current time that Ultron
is in the future and that in order for
them to defeat Ultron they're going to
have to find a way to travel to the
future and so again we see that this is
this idea this question becomes what are
they going to do next what's going to
happen next and as the group is trying
to figure this out we see somebody else
chime in and say that they're going to
get Ultron at this point we switch to
Red Hulk and Red Hulk says they're going
to eliminate Ultron from the face of
existence that is what we learn that who
also is here is March Spectre moon night
along with Natasha Romanov then Natasha
Romanoff tells them that because they
discovered Nick Fury's uh I guess into
the world scenario
miles because they discovered the
location of his end of the world bunker
that they know exactly how it is that
they're going to have to kill Ultron but
that being said I'm gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
you